tell us about your entrepreneur stuff
what are you selling what are you buying
what are you doing
i'm buying and selling uh i'm trying to
sell a couch on craigslist
it's only been [ __ ] on twice
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
what's up everybody this is sebastian
joseph day and i'm mike tyson
and today we got my [ __ ] back
tt
i feel great man you know new new new
lease on life
reordering things you know what i'm
saying putting things in the right
perspective
yeah i'm good man hey man really good
hey man what's hon have you here man
it's crazy because mike i grew up
listening to t-pain
i love [ __ ] i used to go to this class
remember
we didn't know much about the young
brother but he had chris brown with him
on the tour yeah okay
chris is starting out yeah it's crazy
like i grew legit i was like
13 14 growing up so listen to it so it's
just crazy that's dope man that's
amazing man
what's going on man you've been away for
a minute yeah man i had to take a break
you know concentrate on the you know the
things that uh
that are actually important in life you
know family you know friends
relationships just getting back to it
man i'm really not
really putting reordering things as you
know as it is but
yeah man i i had to take a break from it
i think you know that that whole
chase of being number one all the time
was really
really [ __ ] up my my family life and
stuff like that so
i had to rearrange things yeah make sure
to make it
right because that happened to me
yesterday they're hungry they want to be
number one want people to call your name
yeah so superficial now when you
understand
you see some of the damage that you you
know
you caused yeah your family some people
you love
you helped me out a lot with that like
you had like that's just watching you
and watching your journey and
i remember an interview you did where uh
you were showing your belts and
and you know all the stuff in your crib
and you like through one of the belts
was like this means nothing compared to
you know and i was like destroyed so
many that destroyed so many people that
um
loved me and i loved absolutely
absolutely that helped me grow
yeah man that helped that helped me
realize a lot that i needed to
reorder things because it came to a
point that where you know
i wouldn't even have my wife living in
the same house as me
because i was like no no listen listen
my wife lives to wear here and i listen
we had two houses right how much money
you need it's just
right i haven't had money like that
it's not right but it's not wrong either
i don't know
how to do it deal with this situation
yeah man i just wanted to i wanted to
concentrate on just being number one
and i felt like if i had a family in the
same house with me and i wasn't going to
be able to do it and then i would just
realize that wasn't
you know as you know as you get older
you know family becomes one for sure we
all do this together the team effort
you know that now but just
yeah for sure absolutely yeah no it's a
different feeling man but
getting to it and actually having those
things in order that
it just feels better i didn't know it
was going to so it wasn't like a
priority back then but now i know how
that feels and it it
it feels much better and you're not
chasing it and just
willing to call you you live through all
your experiences
absolutely absolutely not many answers
to here from there
that it helps man and it helps to have
you know it helps to have that
information like you know i got like i'm
saying you helped me by showing people
that
you know this reordering can actually
bring happiness
never give up on yourself you gotta
believe that you know
you want to be here more than people
want to see you not here
absolutely know absolutely that's very
true yeah
i do feel that good lord yeah i feel
that the most
because there's a lot of people that
would rather may not be here at all
yeah and something we helped them at one
time mm-hmm they got used to
they were very accustomed to us helping
them
yeah destroy us for sure so we don't
help them do that anymore yeah
and as soon as you all the way at rock
bottom that's when they're like well
i guess i'll see if you come back up
give me a call man
go to the next person they go down there
with you to get you to do some
sell your soul absolutely yeah they
don't give up that easy
you think they give up that evening
that's
good i just suck
right they just leave those evil spirits
went away there
right nowhere that's true man yeah yeah
let's take a right let's stick around
just see what what's what's that little
bit left
what's that little bit left like they
hate you and they want you to hate you
mm-hmm just so they can get you to do
anything they need
so you you first started with a rap
group called
nappy heads oh yeah y'all had that song
that blew up
yeah robbery robbery and like a terrible
name off
right off the bat god damn it i just
realized that
but how'd that come about how'd that
come about um we were just remixing
songs man it was actually a remix of my
neck my back by kaya
and uh the song blew up it went crazy i
don't know
how that happened i mean we started
performing in in
in our city and then somehow we started
getting wider and wider we
reached the tri-state area and yeah the
[ __ ] just blew up
and then you know as as is with a group
of [ __ ] we all started hating each
other
that was just that was the downfall that
was it that was it i don't think you
guys never felt that every time i hear
your song now
it just brings happiness you never know
negative vibe about you that's what i'm
saying i feel like you're such a
positive
dude yeah i i am y'all just young
young young and just young we was
getting money the money was getting
split different ways my dad was the
manager of the group
that never works out
you know my dad would like give us media
training and [ __ ] like that and you know
everybody was
thinking that he was taking care of me
more than anybody else and he thought
he was double dipping in the money that
everybody thought that he was taking
money from everybody here's all that
[ __ ] man
it's a group it's a group of black dudes
so when you decide to go solo so how'd
that go about obviously
you know all that stuff was going on the
crazier thing was everybody was going
solo already
i was the last one in the group because
everybody went so
everybody thought that they were doing a
solo album behind the group's back but
everybody was doing a secret solo
project but
i was the one recording it
everybody was using my studio to make a
secret
solo album and then at the end i was
just like well [ __ ]
i should probably prepare for this group
to not be a thing anymore yeah
and then everybody when they were young
they [ __ ] up like yeah
big time that's crazy when i was young i
made so many bad mistakes like that
about friends and stuff jesus yeah if we
would have stuck to it man would have
been would have been a pretty big deal
you had one i had one of them where you
made mistakes and stuff you just and
your friends
and and you put my friends out there
again mm-hmm
yeah isn't that awesome yeah yeah the
best times of your life with this person
i never again
talk to them yeah you try to rekindle
things sometimes you just don't it's
just not to work yeah yeah
i couldn't work out but not i was
it i like didn't have a choice
[ __ ] yeah i didn't have a choice but
to go solo everybody
everybody had already made their choice
and i was like i'm just i guess i'm
gonna play catch up
yeah and do my own too because this [ __ ]
ain't about to be a thing anymore
you were like so you were like trying to
catch up everyone was doing their thing
yeah everybody was doing solo projects
and i was the one recording all this
[ __ ]
and he was in my studio and i'm like
what the hell
are y'all just doing like solo joints
just off to the side like
you know you have proteges young people
no i was the youngest in the group i'm
talking right this minute oh no
no no i can't i don't want to take
nobody through without but
no you got so much to offer you think so
well i think so yeah that's why you're
on this show [ __ ]
you ain't lying though that might that
might be a point
yeah uh that might be a point got some
new music coming up not a ton of new
music
i got a lot of new music this music is
more
free this is my first independent album
i don't have labeled
management i got i got rid of the whole
deal and this is the name of the
name of the uh album is precious stones
yeah yeah and it's uh basically
it's about digging deeper within you
know seeing the diamonds on the surface
you know you dig a little deeper
and you find those real precious stones
you know uh we've always been told that
uh diamonds are so rare and you know
they're
they're the hardest thing in the world
and you know you they cost this much and
i'm like well
they're so rare why are there so many of
them you know i want to see the colors i
want to see the different cuts i want to
see
the precious stones within all of us i
mean we got to look past the
we know that we know the price of
everything but the value of nothing we
have to know what is
what it means to you yeah yeah can mean
nothing to someone else but it can mean
the world to you
absolutely one man's trash you know what
i'm saying so it's it's
it's digging deeper man it's important
and i felt like i dug
a lot deeper into myself and then looked
at you know
looked at myself from the inside our
minds um our mind is not structured
the fathom who we are yes take away
everything think away um do you see you
think a way every
any way that anybody can give us
information that was from a human being
take it all away and who are we
take all the weight god i know man's
information
yeah you know just everything man any
man or woman had to do with it
yeah that's take that away and what do
you have
yeah that's oh man i'm gonna be thinking
about this for two years
oh my god listen dick i'm on all these
[ __ ] mushroom guys
don't listen to me man
what do you think is going on here these
mushrooms man
i haven't been muslim for six months oh
my god
oh [ __ ] i'll take something yesterday i
probably should
no but you ever think about that all the
time
i've never thought about that
[Laughter]
that's incredible man all this means i
knew it was [ __ ] too
and if i didn't have it i would be
nothing
yeah i don't know how you came up with
that thought man that was [ __ ] up
i always thought about where did this
thought come from i was i
also want something and i might say hey
i want to know something
right and that's how does that happen i
don't know how the [ __ ] that happens
[Laughter]
oh my god yeah that's gonna have me
thinking for a long time
that's not some [ __ ] he can't spring
that on me mike
[Laughter]
that's crazy man i don't know i think
about i'm on the stump um the shrooms
always tell me that
[ __ ] you're dead
whoa it killed my ego right away oh my
god but yeah
just thinking about thoughts how do you
think about thoughts
oh no oh my god
that that blew my mind you know how do
you know shame how do you
how do you know not to take off for your
clothes how do you know that's
embarrassment
i take a dump right you know
yeah like what is how do you learn that
where did that come from
what did that come about
yeah we did that but they they'd call
you a savage
i guess if you grew up in a cave and not
had anybody to
show you those different emotions and
things like how would you know
what emotions are i'm [ __ ] myself up
and ain't safe hey ain't safe we got to
stop talking about that because i'm
we're going to get into some some weird
[ __ ] in a second no really
no it's never that weird um it's not
weirder than what this world has seen i
heard this
is an interesting plan absolutely for
sure
it's different it is it is um
hopefully we get through it we got
through all the [ __ ] we've done so far
no but god is good man yeah even when he
looks bad god that's good
absolutely absolutely i mean everything
you know falls into place when it's
supposed to so
you know there's no there's no definite
way there's no plan there's no that you
know any of us could have at all there's
always
the plan was already in place no it was
written i believe
i'm a strong believer it was red yeah
yeah
it was already in place just not by us
who do you have on your album with you
i got um ty dolla sign
trying to get blue on there blue
vandross um
working on carlos santana carlos santana
um thinking about jay balvin
we gotta we're still in progress so
we're just like just going around and
getting
verses from the new guys jay balvin and
all this
yeah it's just hot just to the top
oh just immediately so yeah we're trying
to
get the new talent on there man and you
know and embrace the
next generation and [ __ ] like that so
you know it's a working program
we're going crazy i really wish you the
best in all that kalani
why am i so bad at this listen tell the
world
look at the word tell the world about
what you got to offer man
terrible at this yeah kalani just
dropped the song we're about to shoot a
video
to that and uh in a couple days oh yeah
which i mean
tell us about your entrepreneur stuff
what are you selling what are you buying
what are you doing
i'm buying and selling uh i'm trying to
sell a couch on craigslist
[Laughter]
i'm telling you mike if you need it we
need extra couch
in the spot
i gotta try to do this [ __ ] it's on
lebron i can bring it right over here
oh [ __ ] i've been trying to sell across
the country man nobody wants to buy this
couch
it's only been [ __ ] on twice it's not
like a big deal that's it
two times ain't done deal
i'm trying to find out whether you can't
where's your gallery can you see the
[ __ ] couch
no i got i got pictures of it but nobody
you guys see it in person you're not
allowed
to take my words
he felt like characters
[Laughter]
man nappy boy gaming uh that nappy boy
drifting we got we got a bunch of stuff
man uh you know
holy [ __ ] you know i'm always trying to
do something man that couch is available
though if anybody
you know all right
holy [ __ ] yeah man no we got i mean a
few business ventures man uh nappy boy
radio podcast
what got my podcast yeah
[Laughter]
how many views do we have again
talk [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh
[ __ ] nappy boy radio podcast we're gonna
get back on that oh
[ __ ] i'm there with you anyway
absolutely absolutely
that was that was very well timed listen
to
where are you from originally
tallahassee florida alas in florida
all right yes yes yes so who's in your
family that's the muslim
my dad everybody i was born i knew that
someone had told me that yeah
yeah my dad was the right-hand man to
seduce
yeah yeah so yeah so you know uh
my dad met you a couple times and then
uh
he's talking about you all the time it
was just the most amazing story so
but uh yeah they they um yeah my dad
converted
and college i think and then yeah i was
born with everybody
so yeah this is great absolutely
absolutely we did the right thing
listen as i said before
all these people out here besides
selling the couch
if you have anything to say these people
say something
i gotta do this [ __ ] [ __ ] radio station
man
it's red and black by the way if anybody
wants something random
rather than that yeah it's red and black
if anybody you know want to coordinate
with the house
let me know
oh yeah you know you're smoking that man
yeah man
i'm i'm more of a drinker dude yeah i
see that and i did too much yesterday
which is why i'm trying to finish this
yelling
i gotta figure it out oh good
definitely gotta uh figure out my wine
intake
it's not not on a great pace right now
ah
wine and mushrooms was not a solid
choice yesterday
hey it's a beautiful choice you think so
cause you made it
i'm i'm [ __ ] feeling it i'm really
questioning it
there's nothing that you decide is wrong
oh whatever
you make is right even though you have
to suffer from it it was the right one
to make it's kicking my ass right now
i'm like i gotta tell you man
it's beautiful ah
i might have to kick it back up you know
what i'm gonna do next thoughts
see these [ __ ] next time i'm
gonna have my open space where you i'll
probably be moving my rings
where y'all could people could perform
and [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
yeah man he's just gonna go crazy in
here
i don't think what else can you fit in
this place man i'm gonna move the
[ __ ] ring the ring's gonna be the
[ __ ] snow the rainbow state of the
rings will be the stage
the ring is gonna be the stage yeah
speakers from the ceiling
yes a couple of minutes all about
that's hard yeah call me back for that
when you're ready i know yours doing
bill
listen listen you don't know like to
come see when chris rock when
little chris brown used to be with your
crew all the time on tour with you all
right yes i was just telling them that's
it man
don't be sleeping on this [ __ ]
man this is the king
so you for your loving music like how'd
that come about i remember reading
something about um you kind of dropping
out of school just to pursue
it right is that correct yeah well my
dad took me out of school oh this [ __ ]
know your information
like what's going on we're gonna keep
you here
you know just no you doing the right
[ __ ] though but
killing it so tell us yeah so go down
get into that [ __ ] talk about it yeah
talk about his life
so your dad took you out yeah my dad
took me out of school
i got out of school yeah he did that
[ __ ] devil worship and [ __ ] right
i'm sorry i just gotta have to say that
[ __ ]
that's controversy
but my school my middle school had just
implemented
a new dress code to where all the boys
had to tuck their shirts in
okay and i was fat i didn't want to do
that but just gonna see my gut more i
don't wanna do that [ __ ]
i didn't tuck my shirt in and they
suspended me for the last one
what happened when your father took you
out of school that that's when
music really kicked off that's when it
started happening
they suspended me for not having my
shirt tucked in and that would have mean
that
mean i wouldn't be able to graduate i
would have had one can we keep it a
stack right now
yeah was it like hey t-pain could you
please tuck in your shirt and you were
like
[ __ ] you you're [ __ ] you were
like you were like yeah exactly sorry
authority wasn't like the best thing for
me
but i didn't like i didn't like go off
and [ __ ] yeah just like just
mr knives i'm talking your shirt i'm not
doing that man
chugging your shirt now that's that's
suspension no
that's fine i do want to be home no
all right we're canceling everybody out
peace
i would have had to repeat the eighth
grade just because i had my shirt on
and my dad was like well [ __ ] this like
they obviously
my grades were like they were there
tricky
a lot of different letters
the alphabet right right but you know i
would have passed i would have passed
eighth grade if i
if i had tucked my damn shirt in and
then my dad was like they obviously
don't care about grace if they'll hold
you back
yeah a whole year just because of the
show i was sweating so bad at my
spelling bees boys
can you please spell yeah
but hey listen it was a blessing in
disguise it was
it was i had time my dad got me my own
studio
everything worked out it was it was a
blessing i obviously didn't want to go
to school
yeah so that was great no this nobody
wanted to actually go to school
so it's curious to know so okay so one
thing that i know since you know
listening to you as a young age i know
for sure
that i gotta get somebody get me what he
[Laughter]
at least one whatever it is i don't have
one please
everyone's a nice show you have to talk
about people talk some [ __ ] i don't know
what happened
here go ahead yeah
no idea so so you being the pioneer of
auto tune
but how did that come about how did you
even find autotune how did that
become affirmative search for it for two
years that was
terrible it was such a terrible search
it was the first like
i had to go through dvds of like
different effects and plug-ins and stuff
like that because i didn't know what it
was called
so i just had to get cracked you know
effects and stuff like that from my
homeboys and just go through
every point so so someone showed it so
someone showed it to you
no i heard it on a commercial once
[Laughter]
i heard a [ __ ] on the commercial it was
one of them uh them cds that's like just
like the mixtapes they used to sell
legal legal mixtapes okay
wouldn't let [ __ ] do it but put it on
the commercial and put it on your tv it
was fine
no i was one of the mixtapes um you see
something
push it push it
it was if you had my love by jennifer
lopez of the dark child remix
and he used it for like two seconds on
that song and i heard that part and i
was like i gotta find out what that is
i gotta find that you just researched it
and i went crazy went crazy
i went crazy yeah i wasn't super good at
the internet back then but i knew how to
get what i was looking for it took me it
took me about a year and a half year and
changed
to find it and then i studied it some
more once i found it and
learned how to use it correctly you
became a bad
he could sing his ass off that's why he
didn't even never even needed the auto
team he just found like a whole new like
revenue of it is this true with this
young man saying um
it's a it's an opinion-based statement
but
i mean i agree though he won the mass
singer
get the
[Applause]
what you did you did a great job with in
the mad singer of switching up what you
were singing
yeah so that's what people love yeah
yeah this this dude was saying every
single rock
he was saying rock he was singing pop he
was singing everything like yeah i
didn't want to go straight up [ __ ]
[ __ ]
found me out you're the bad singer and
he wanted
season
[Laughter]
yeah man yeah first season kicked it off
yeah and honestly
like guy like me oh this is if i think
i would think god is just um
showing me how connie could be to me if
i just
go towards his side a little bit
i'm sure yeah that seems like a step in
the right direction right
now you come over here some more be kind
enough and we can let
this good stuff you won't happen so
speaking of
the mass singer do you think the tiny
desk performance also changed people's
like perspective of you
oh yeah for sure oh yeah when people
heard my real voice
yeah yeah they don't nobody knows that
like i do that [ __ ] and there's like a
lot of footage of me doing it and oh
everybody just ignores that
you do the music for the mad singer
that's a that's a career changer
he's a producer he's the medusa director
extraordinaire
yeah i'm gonna be involved in that one
yeah we'll figure that out though that's
something else
but obviously in the positive sense that
it changed people's perception oh yeah
absolutely
absolutely yeah i mean so you never was
negative what was negative about you
everybody was just like you you're one
trick pony
you know you got you got auto-tune and
that's it and i'm like i got
grammys and stuff though you start
playing
now we're missing leave that playing
all right i'll just go away a little bit
of people cause you to make a whole
bunch of people say
yeah the negative stuff is always the
loudest this this right here
the negative stuff is always a lot like
i probably won't reply to like any
positive tweets
but the second somebody say [ __ ] t pay
and i'm i'm i'm i got a full day ready
i got a full day ahead of me i'm
tweeting this [ __ ] back
you got known the reality with nothing
what am i what
if no one told you who you are for man
man or woman whoever anonymous
information we read or anything take all
that away and who are you
you gotta stop hitting me with these
hard-hitting questions man yeah
take all the information that we got was
just lies all these lies and some of
them are just
someone else's opinion or somebody won a
war
so he's gonna annihilate you if you
don't conceive this the way he
perceives and should be conceived and um
take all that away and who are you this
question is kicking my ass
that's [ __ ] sure well i do know i'm
still
a beautiful chocolate man okay well you
feel me subjective
you feel me mike and mike you still a
champ you feeling me
[Laughter]
i don't know but what were you 10
million years ago
jesus like
[Laughter]
well you you probably wasn't even black
[ __ ]
i was probably in my dad's balls to be
honest i mean i don't know
they found a country under turkey nine
thousand years old
what they've heard a country under
our country under turkey yeah so you
know we get built on top of the
city empires yeah and it's 9 000 years
older than that
no way yeah that's trippy so how the
hell we're going to rewrite history now
jesus you know human beings don't know
nothing we don't know [ __ ] nothing
yeah that's scary as hell it's a whole
[ __ ] spot under us
yeah i ain't i gotta understand how that
might
build on top of that though like what
are you i don't even know like that's
that's some that's some savage [ __ ] i'm
not gonna cop you imagine like new york
just being underground at some point
what well you talk about new york city
yeah they think about
one time new york city was owned by
native americans
oh yeah and they all had to be
slaughtered to be what it is today
all right i don't i didn't come here to
cry
having a good day
all right native american we ain't gonna
keep this [ __ ]
i'm just curious what would your advice
be to like you know
young artists and signing record labels
[ __ ] the label do you think
independence right or get with an
independent label
yeah at least don't don't sign
for money obviously don't time for money
sign for resources yeah
you know if that's just if you don't
have i mean it's so easy to
put out a song now it's just you just
you can make a song on your phone and
then post it to the internet from your
phone yeah no
you know
it's a lot of dope independent labels
out here that can actually facilitate a
real artist and
actually have the resources to get that
artist where they need to be but you
know
is it like super necessary if you work
hard enough you'll get you'll get to
where you're going eventually
uh labels just give you that extra push
and make it make the process faster
what is that deal that they have that
even
if you leave the group you got to pay
360.
something like this
well any deal whoa all the money gotta
come back stop the bus stop the bus
brother stop
about that any any deal all the money
got to come back and but in particular
deals
uh even if you just stop everything like
all you they they start getting assets
and
you know if you ain't making the money
we'll we'll we'll make it work
we'll make it happen they get pretty
[ __ ] bad dude
they get pretty bad i started learning
about bad deals once i got in them
yeah it wasn't that's not it's not like
an apparent thing they're like hey you
want a bunch of money
yeah guys these people holding your life
yo
yeah so obviously you experienced
something oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah i mean you know most of them
got resolved because i got
smart and sober that's
the lady will keep up mike do you have
anything to give us
i still have these matches and cars and
stuff and the ladies
i don't know how i kept all this [ __ ] i
just don't know how i thought
really and then i guess eventually um
they died or something
i couldn't i couldn't pay the tax i
can't pay they can't get no money for me
so they
they made it lower and ah yeah
i still can't
waiting it never happened like just mike
just let him just never
listen it just never [ __ ] had all
praised people in love but it just never
happened i'm waiting for these people to
come
start knocking on the door and all this
this just never
[Laughter]
so t i'm just curious so you've had so
many
so many bangers like i could list them
off
what what one was your favorite and
obviously you know buy you a drink i
felt like was the thing that
like took you to another atmosphere yeah
that was a different level
yeah how did how did that come about how
did that feel
with the strippers
why was i why was i 13 years old 14
years old singing
i'm in love with a stripper
i've never heard someone talk about a
stripper make it sound so beautiful
before my life it was pretty beautiful
hey hey how's it coming my whole life
was trying to save
some legendary
um now my homeboy is trying to save
strippers in the club and uh
the song was a joke i was literally
making fun of him
and i was just recording random [ __ ] and
we were in snake on your studio
and big boy walked in and he was like
this [ __ ] jam and i was like yup it's
coming out
now it's not a joke anymore
[Laughter]
yeah it was a joke we're just in studio
[ __ ] around a big boy said it was
dope so i was like yep yeah it sure is
okay
oh shout out to your friend out here
saving these hoes
shout out to your boy that's a big boy
yeah yeah
that's fine um and uh son man he is just
so
anti me and you know he just has his own
views he's really straight
going he's just he's just he's just so
opposite me in his mind really yeah
the [ __ ] is straight forward that came
yeah
i don't believe that
18 19 years old not ivy school kid just
nearly oh he
oh he went crazy he went straight in
yeah oh my god
yeah that was very opposite
[Laughter]
you know like i look after you like
mexican [ __ ] man
you don't hang out with no blacks or
mexicans well just come in this room
real quick
quick quick little quick little test
real quick
hey it it is but uh so then buy you a
drink obviously took you to another
atmosphere
yeah now what was the story behind that
man i actually didn't want it the trick
[ __ ]
buying a bunch of drinks for people you
said you did you didn't want to do it i
didn't want to do that song at all
it was the one song i like needed on my
album it was snap music was popular at
the time yeah
and my anr was like dude you gotta do at
least one snap song i was like i'll do
it but i'm gonna do
my version of it and that was like the
last song i recorded for the album and
that's what made them like okay we can
put this
on now and i just i did not want to do
that [ __ ] song
why did you stop i had to
why because it was taking over
everything just my career was just
my life yeah like you know i i wanted to
like you know
my my kids yeah made two different
people like when they saw me on tv
they would call that person other daddy
oh
yeah when i would get home like you know
they wouldn't run to me and [ __ ] like
that it's like i've been on the road for
[ __ ] too much like you ain't seen me
and it's like we we saw you
you've been you've been on the tv we're
sorry
all right so you know once that [ __ ]
started taking over life like that i
just realized
this you know being at the top wasn't
super important
[Laughter]
relationship with my daughter after
going through that
yeah that's just daddy i don't have no
relationship with mm-hmm
mm-hmm that [ __ ] hurts man oh that's
what sucks make you feel useless
yeah for sure to you know have that
go on and you know being called other
daddy when i walk in the house and [ __ ]
it's just like
okay i can probably i can probably go
ahead and stop this for a minute
yeah just reset it
you know you don't lose you don't lose
[ __ ] like that you know you don't
you know you don't lose talent you know
you know i was like i can get back to it
i'm sure i won't be you know in the
public eye as much and [ __ ] like that
and
you know it wouldn't be going off the
momentum but i still should be able to
get back to it at some point so i don't
think that's going to pull me
up but that's real yeah i'm telling you
that's
real though that's real for you though
to do that i think it's like put your
whole career on pause i commend you for
that man
man and just focus on your family and
kids man absolutely that's huge
it took me a while to learn that that
was way more important but i did that
[ __ ] learned
ivy league [ __ ] because all right well
uh
we did it we did it i'm sebastian joseph
dave
hey mike mike tyson i'm t-pain aka
you're getting it
hot boxing [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
you